so Donald Trump has been playing this
pathetically transparent game claiming
he really wants that molar report
release let him see it
I'm exonerated it would be great for me
to have the molar report published and
anyone with any common sense knew all
along that this wasn't true because
Muller said according to William bars
letter that based on his investigation
he cannot exonerate Donald Trump from
obstruction of justice charges which
means that by by logical extension
molars report is going to contain at
least some evidence of obstruction of
justice if it didn't he'd conceivably be
able to exonerate Donald Trump from
obstruction of justice which he said
according to William Barr that he's not
able to do this has always been obvious
to critical thinkers and it's now
becoming public Trump in the White House
are all of a sudden backing away from
their enthusiasm about the release of
the Moller report what started with let
it come out let people see it it's up to
the Attorney General but I wanted out
that has become Donald Trump's advisors
privately saying you know what comes
from the Moller report could have some
staying power in terms of it being
damaging to Donald Trump we're getting
into the 2020 election this might not be
the best time for that to be released
Trump before said it's up to the
Attorney General but it wouldn't bother
me at all and now a senior White House
official has spoken to New York
magazines Olivia Newton and said that
there will be quote plenty of
unfavorable things about the president
in the full report which we think will
eventually come out so let's not go
overboard saying there's no wrongdoing
let's move on Donald Trump is also
laying the groundwork for ignoring or
belittling or continuing to try to
prevent through Mitch McConnell the
reports full release tweeting yesterday
quote there is no amount of testimony or
document production that can satisfy
Jerry Nadler or shifty Adam Schiff it is
now time to focus exclusively on
properly running our great Capitol
country sort of implying that maybe
rather than worrying about releasing the
molar report it's just time to move on
and do stuff now that he's been cleared
so Trump is now calling demands to
publish the report a disgrace and a
waste of time rather than what it was
last week which is something that he
welcomed and wouldn't have any problem
with it all I actually don't think that
this is anything more than Trump last
week not realizing that this thing
didn't exonerate him I think Pat that
Trump didn't know that the Moller report
is not the same thing as William bars
four-page letter now that Trump is
realizing that now that Trump's
attorneys have probably sat him down and
said listen he couldn't exonerate you
from obstruction that means the full
reports going to have some damaging
stuff I think Trump just didn't know it
then he knows it now and now he's not so
gung-ho about this thing being released
or maybe before he thought that the
obstruction of justice evidence just had
to do with him firing James Comey
threatening or trying to push Jeff
Sessions into resigning maybe the
witness tampering stuff having to do
with Michael Cohen and now he's caught
wind that maybe there's more here that
the public didn't know about because if
we see the smaller report and it's just
basically things that we've already
heard about things that have already
been covered by the media it's not gonna
be too too damaging to him but if we
learn some new things that certainly
would be and if Trump found out about
that he would definitely want to block
the Moller report that maybe and this
has been the pattern Trump's fine
sitting down with robert muller for an
interview until his attorneys knowing
that donald trump lies uncontrollably
say no no no we're going to have some
answers submitted in writing instead of
you sitting down with everybody which by
the way was obviously the correct legal
decision if you're donald trump and you
hire attorneys that's exactly what you
want them doing we don't have to come up
with strange hypotheses or far-fetched
ideas about what's happening here the
full molar report is damaging to trump
period it's release we'll put that
content back in the public spotlight the
timing won't be good for Trump as the
20/20 campaign continues to build no
conspiracies no suggestions that Trump
will be personally implicated in
colluding with Vladimir Putin on a
one-on-one level we never expected that
but there's going to be damaging
information at minimum about Donald
Trump's obstruction and probably more so
now Trump in the White House aren't so
thrilled about the idea of this report
being released Mitch McConnell by the
way knew this from the beginning from
from the beginning Mitch McConnell twice
blocked the resolutions in the Senate
which called for the release of the
Moller report he knew exactly what to
expect if the contents of the report
were released it just took Trump a
little longer to come around on it one
of today's sponsors is Nord VPN Nord VPN
protects your privacy and keeps you safe
online I now use it on all of my devices
and they are giving everybody in our
audience a 75% discount on a three-year
subscription which comes out to under
three dollars a month plus a whole month
free when you go to Nord VPN comm slash
David Pakman and use the coupon code
david pakman all one-word Nord VPN
really is the type of sponsor that I
love to have because they're huge
supporters of independent progressive
media they also support other
progressive shows so you should feel
really good about giving Nord VPN your
business but most importantly this is a
really useful thing to have on your
computer and on your phone you know that
I talk all the time on the show about
the importance of Internet privacy big
data hacks internet censorship by
governments it is with these concerns in
mind that four friends came together in
2012 and created nordley PN which lets
you surf the web anonymously websites
can't track what you're doing around the
internet which can make sure that these
big companies like Google and Facebook
don't invade your privacy and use your
personal data for their profit Nord VPN
encrypts all of your data so your
passwords bank accounts credit card
information all stays safe even when
you're connected to those sketchy free
public Wi-Fi networks very important it
could not be easier to use it's a
extremely simple you don't have to be a
tech expert to set it up join over a
million other Nord VPN users worldwide
start taking your privacy more seriously
don't let companies spy on you and don't
let criminals steal your identity david
pakman show viewers can get 75% off a
three-year plan of Nord VPN that's under
three bucks a month plus one whole month
for free just go to Nord VPN comm slash
David Pakman I've put a link down below
underneath this video then use the
coupon code David Pakman at checkout all
one word